[Music]
she was the light of their lives and the
murder of 23 year old ashley murphy has
stunned ireland the president and his
wife comforted her parents brother
sister and boyfriend as they arrived for
her funeral the primary school teachers
class of five and six-year-olds had
waited outside the church to say goodbye
the prime minister thieshik mihal martin
was also there to hear her family's
emotional tribute ashleen epitomized the
beauty of life
shared her passion
gifts and talents but orders so
generously
we pray for her friends colleagues and
students may ashleen's legacy live in
the hearts of all she touched
lord hear us lord graciously hear us
ashlyne murphy was attacked while
jogging beside the grand canal in
tullamore county awfully the nature of
her death has prompted an outpouring of
grief
anger and hope for a change in attitudes
we pray that the many vigils that took
place in memory of ashling mark the
beginning of an end to violence against
women
may the candlelight tributes bring an
everlasting hope to all those that live
in fear
[Music]
in a post on social media ashlyn's
sister amy described her as the heart of
their family she excelled in the sport
of camogie and played the fiddle her
family well known in the traditional
music community
and here deep in the heart of ireland
musicians honored one of their own as
she made her final journey
david blevins sky news in my bolus